(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
I mean, the strength coming out from you.
I'm serious, I'm not just stroking you.
It's, you've got something pretty magical here.
You don't know how much that means to me,
because I, you have lived that life.
Well, we have lived parallel lives,
Yeah.
In many ways,
So hearing that...
Well, you have something magical here.
The feeling is amazing. So you're gonna,
you're gonna take over television.
(audience cheering)
You have no idea how much your your approval means to me.
Oh, thank you.
I mean, let's talk about, you know, 1979,
what was that decade like for you?
Because there was some really crazy things that happened.
'79 to '89 from a professional point of view
were the dark years because I had lost my career.
From a personal point of view,
I couldn't have been happier because I got married in '78.
I finally found the love of my life.
I could spend the rest of the show,
just talking about how she saved me.
I dated her secretly for three and a half years
because I didn't want Tiger Beat to find out.
(Donny laughing)
and then once the news got out that I got married
and maybe some of you did this, I won't hold it against you.
(Drew chuckling)
But fans literally had Donny Osman record burning parties
(audience gasping)
and sent the most scathing letters to Debbie.
And she's this sweet little girl from Billings, Montana.
She is the most amazing woman and saved my life really
because I was going through some really dark times.
It took me about 10 years
before things started kicking back in again,
'cause that's when Soldier Of Love hit in '89.
But I had tried Broadway in a show
called Little Johnny Jones.
And we opened and closed the same night,
that hurts.
(Donny laughing)
And I couldn't get a record deal.
I couldn't even get arrested.
I mean, it was, I couldn't do anything.
It was, everything was gone.
You getting married, the fans abandon.
Yeah.
When you got married,
how did you know to lean into your wife,
instead of saying, you're the root cause of this?
How did you know to lean in with family
and see the reality of what was happening
rather than turn it on them?
Okay.
Because of what state I was in
prior to getting married to her.
There was a concert that I did in Hawaii
and the place was packed,
thousands and thousands of people screaming.
And I went back to our condo.
We had a condo there at the time
and I found a little corner in the room in that condo.
And I rolled myself up into a ball
and started crying my eyes out, uncontrollably.
And my brother, Jay, walks in and he sees me.
He said, "Donnie, what's wrong?"
And I said, "Jay, I'm lonely.
I'm just lonely."
He said, "Donnie,
20,000 girls were just screaming your name.
How could you be lonely?"
I said, "I don't know, but I'm lonely."
I was in such a desperate place
that Debbie pulled me out of it.
And whenever I make a decision in my life,
the first thing I think about is her,
how does it affect her?
And then the second, how does it affect my children?
And the third now is how does that affect my grandchildren?
Then I'm fourth.
If all four of those are a green light, then I'll do it.
And I think that's what's really helped
this 43 year marriage is that she comes first.
But I love what I do.
It's not, I mean the applause and everything,
when I walked out and everybody was just applauding
and everything, the love that ensued is just, it's euphoric.
And here's the problem.
If I depended on that all the time,
then my downs would be really down.
Yup.
So what I do, and people make fun of me for it
because I go home, I'll mow my grass.
I'll take my garbage out.
I'll do the domestic things that,
you know, I could have somebody do all that for me.
But I do that because it's down to balancing.
I look at my friend,
Michael Jackson and I had a great relationship.
We would laugh.
We'd call each other on the phone
and we'd laugh about the similarities of our families
and the difference, the last time I spoke with him,
he said, "I just need some normalcy in my life."
I said, "Come to my home, let your kids swim with my kids.
No one will know you're there."
He said, "I think I need to do that."
And he never took me up on it.
That's the last time I spoke with him.
So looking at that and all the other celebrities
and peers and whatever,
colleagues that have influenced my life
and I've been around,
I see so many people have lost it
because they don't know how to balance.
Yep.
I love the adulation.
I love the standing ovations at the end of a show.
I love that. I eat it up.
And it's a drug and I need it,
(Donny laughing)
but I also need to go home and be a father,
and a husband and a grandpa.
You know, sometimes we can feel sorry for ourselves.
"I've been dealt such a bad hand of cards.
Why God, why?"
Well, do something about it.
Play those cards.
Play those cards, you know, do something with your life.
Don't constantly feel sorry for yourself,
I mean, and I have,
I've sat back and I'm guilty of it too.
Say, why, why, why?
And then you just say,
"Give me the strength to just play these cards
and make something of my life."
I so agree with that.
(audience clapping)
All right, you had Donnie and Marie.
I mean, first of all,
let's just talk about the first show.
Who?
That's why,
Johnny and Marie.
Oh, Marie, oh yeah, Marie.
Marie, that's right.
I mean,
that show was just so major for everybody.
We had so much fun.
I mean, what was that like?
We had no idea how much work we were getting into.
And because we were doing like,
as far as music is concerned, an album a week,
let alone the comedy and the performances.
And it was just overwhelming,
but we were young and we had the stamina,
Yeah.
but it was huge.
It was great for the time.
I've embraced it.
The memories of working with my sister.
Yes, there were times that were difficult,
but I loved working with her.
It's, the only word I can call it is magic.
There's a magic between the two of us
that when we're both on stage together,
something clicks.
Okay, so not only do you have a new album,
but you have a new Vegas show.
And I was wondering what you could tell us about
both those things.
Well, you know,
a lot of people will say,
"Well, is it going to be like the Donnie and Marie show?
No,
I did not want to try to recreate something
that she's not going to be a part of.
Right.
So this show was so fun to put together
because it's, talk about this is your life.
I've tried to fit six decades of show business
into a 90-minute show, and I did it.
I just released my 65th album. And I thought,
(audience cheering)
so, I thought, so, so,
Do you mean this one?
Yeah, there it is.
So it's titled "Start Again."
But I thought, okay, which album
and which music do I put into this show?
So I said, I'm going to put every song
I've ever recorded into the show.
There is a segment,
and it's my favorite segment of the show,
where the audience takes over.
All 65 albums are on the huge screens behind me.
They can pick any album, any song from any album.
And we go three, four, and we do it.
Well, I cannot wait to see this Opus.
I am gonna be there in Vegas.
Oh, please let me know when you're there.
Oh, are you kidding me?
Oh, please let me know.
Oh, I'm there.
I am there.
(audience clapping)
I cannot thank you enough for this life-changing,
meaningful conversation.
Go to our website, obviously,
for all the information on everything you heard today
about the show and the album and everything.
Oh, also everybody in the audience
is going home with this album.
Oh, fantastic.
(audience cheering)
(Donny chuckling)
Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
(upbeat music)